Back in the Golden Age of comic books, nobody
probably thought twice about a character's
sexuality.
But times change, and audiences want to find
more ways to relate to the stories they consume.
Readers want to know that superheroes don't
discriminate, and creators have responded
throughout the years.
Here are a few superheroes who aren't afraid
to be themselves.
Iceman
When the X-Men were first introduced in 1963,
the team consisted of Cyclops, Beast, Angel,
Marvel Girl, and Iceman.
Over the years, Iceman evolved a number of
different looks and even had a few relationships.
But it wasn't until a storyline in 2015 when
a time-displaced, teenage version of Iceman
was introduced that psychic Jean Grey discovered
he was gay.
Since the Iceman we'd all been reading since
the 1960s never indicated this was the case,
except maybe once, the characters had a talk.
It was revealed that Iceman couldn't cope
with being both a mutant and gay, but since
he had to deal with his powers openly, he
suppressed his own sexuality to the point
where he refused to even think about it.
After talking with his teen self, Iceman was
able to come to terms with his feelings, and
the character is now openly gay, arguably
making him Marvel's most powerful character
who is also homosexual.
Northstar
The Canadian mutant known as Northstar is
a member of Alpha Flight and has had numerous
appearances in the X-Men comics over the years.
He's also Marvel's first openly gay character.
In fact, in issue 51 of Astonishing X-Men,
Northstar marries his husband.
Though not as popular as the X-Men, Alpha
Flight was a team of mutants who operated
north of the border in Canada.
Northstar serves as an integral member of
the team and has a variety of powers including
superhuman speed, flight, and the ability
to fire photonic blasts of energy.
He and the rest of the team were created by
legendary writer John Byrne in 1983, who at
first didn't want to create the team as two-dimensional
nobodies to counter the X-Men.
In order to alleviate his own misgivings,
he created more fleshed out backgrounds for
the characters, which included making Northstar
a gay character.
Unfortunately, Northstar's sexual orientation
could only be hinted at for years, since editorial
policy at the time forbade characters from
being homosexual.
Batwoman
You're probably familiar with Batgirl, the
alter ego of Barbara Gordon, but Batwoman
actually predates her by a few years.
Ironically, she was introduced in the mid-1950s
to as a love interest for Batman, in order
to counter rumors that Batman was gay.
Seduction of the Innocent, a book written
by psychiatrist Fredric Wertham, had called
comics into question for their influence over
children, and in particular called out the
characters of Batman and Robin, suggesting
their relationship was a homosexual one.
Batwoman ended up being axed as a character
midway through the 1960s only to be resurrected
again in 2006.
This time she was given a new twist and was
re-introduced as a gay character herself,
in an effort on DC's part to offer more diverse
characters for their readers.
Rictor
Introduced in the late 1980s, Rictor made
his way through a number of X-titles, including
X-Factor and X-Force, as well as The New Mutants.
His mutant power involves generating seismic
energy, which is basically directing earthquakes
at stuff.
In 2009, Rictor shared a kiss with fellow
X-Force member Shatterstar, the first ever
in a Marvel comic book.
Since that time, the character has been an
open and out gay man.
The relationship between Rictor and Shatterstar
proved to be so popular and well done that
writer Peter David won a GLAAD award for the
portrayal of their relationship in the pages
of X-Factor.
Graymalkin
Even casual Marvel fans may have heard the
word "Graymalkin" pop up now and then.
It's the name of the street where Xavier's
School for Gifted Youngsters was built, as
well as the name of Cable's space station.
And, since 2008, Graymalkin has also been
a mutant with the young X-Men.
How'd he get his name?
His family owned the land on which Xavier's
school was built and the street was named
after them.
As it turns out, though, the character is
over 200 years old, and was caught by his
father as a teen experimenting with another
boy.
Enraged, his father beat him unconscious and
actually buried him alive on the land that
would one day become Xavier's school.
Fortunately for Graymalkin, his mutant powers
activated and saved him from death, putting
him in a kind of hibernation until the present
when he was freed and eventually became a
member of the Young X-Men.
Anole
One of the New X-Men, Anole's mutation is
a number of lizard-like abilities to match
his scaly appearance, including the ability
to crawl up walls, a prehensile tongue, and
adaptive camouflage.
The character was introduced with hints that
he might be gay, given his closeness to his
mentor Northstar.
It was later confirmed as the real deal by
the comics' writers.
Anole has since been praised for being openly
gay while not making every storyline revolve
around that particular aspect of his life.
He's gay, but he's also a superhero, so he
does superhero things that aren't affected
by his sexuality.
In other words, despite looking like a lizard,
he's just a normal guy.
Angela
One of the coolest characters in recent comics
history, Angela was originally created by
Neil Gaiman and Todd McFarlane to be part
of Image Comics' Spawn universe.
However, after a lawsuit over rights, a court
ordered that Angela should revert fully to
Gaiman, who has since sold the character to
Marvel.
Angela was originally a warrior from Heaven
sent to fight the hellspawn.
Once she joined the Marvel Universe, she ended
up with the Guardians of the Galaxy, of all
people, until she has to run off with Odin's
baby to protect it after finding out she,
too, is an Asgardian, and the daughter of
Odin.
Accompanying her is Sera, her companion, friend,
and lover.
Deadpool
Deadpool is played straight in his movie,
but writers and the man in red himself, Ryan
Reynolds, have openly acknowledged Mr. Pool
is actually a lot more fluid in his sexuality
than that.
Reynolds described Deadpool as "pansexual,"
but don't take it from him.
Here's Deadpool co-creator Fabian Nicieza
explaining the Merc's sexuality:
"He can be hetereosexual one day.
And a few days later he can believe 100 percent
that he's not."
Deadpool is ready to have fun with anyone
from moment to moment.
Reynolds has gone on record saying he loves
this aspect of the character and hopes that
in a sequel the character could have a boyfriend,
just because it's another way Deadpool breaks
the boundaries of traditional superhero roles.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!